i gotta say i always have such a great
time talking to you
and then i saw recently that you
described yourself as an introvert and i
thought
i talked to kirsty all the time i've
talked to her
she's fantastic you are a great
interview you've got so much personality
you don't come across as an introvert
because i'm the thing about introverts
is when we're at home
we're practicing how to be human out in
the real world so
i just you know i work on my hi hi
hey you know it gets more casual hey
sure okay how's it going
so i work on it i work on how to
socialize um
think and i'm an actor so i'm faking it
i don't even want to be here you know
talking to me right now is a living hell
that's what you're saying
it's torturous i have no pants on i
don't like it oh okay well
all right well we've got that in common
uh and and you've got spiders
maybe in your hair you don't know i do
you know what's so funny and i have to
bring this up because i thought it was
hilarious
this whole time i thought i just like
misheard and i thought that you were in
nigeria this whole time
cause i thought you were in lagos
no that would first of all that would be
so cool if i was born into
quarantining in nigeria i'm at the largo
theater
l-a-r-g-o in los angeles very famous
old theater but i love that you thought
wow
conan's quarantining in nigeria i
literally thought oh my god he cares
about the theaters in nigeria like
he took his whole team to lagos that's
crazy and then yesterday i realized
oh he's in like west hollywood
look there are a lot of similarities
okay
[Laughter]
they would say